- He runs after me, grabs me,
and he goes,
"What the fuck are you doing?"
And I go, "Living, bro,"
and I punch him in the face
and run away.
Like, there's happy drunk.
There's sad drunk.
I was run-away drunk.
[police siren blaring
in the distance]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[coughs]
Ha! Yes!
[laughs]
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Yeah! Yeah!
Yeah!
[truck horn honks]
♪
[cheers and applause]
- Very, very funny man,
he's got his own podcast
called "My Dumb Friends."
Give it up for Dan St. Germain,
everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- Drugs and alcohol have
affected every area of my life.
It's affected my relationship
with women
and my relationship with sex.
Small aside--
I spent $1,500
to have a escort come over
one night,
and I couldn't get it up,
so I just spend all night
holding her hand...
like it was the first date.
I'm like, "Hey, if I pay extra,
can we do that animal-cracker
scene from 'Armageddon'?"
It's affected my relationship
with my family.
Once I was naked
in my parents' living room
doing lines.
Naked's the official uniform
of cocaine, by the way.
That's like Superman's cape.
And they came home early,
and the only thing
that I could think to say was,
"Uh, uh, don't come in.
I'm masturbating."
You know your life's
in a sad place
if masturbation's
the safe option
with your parents.
And then when they turned
their back,
I took the rest of the cocaine,
put it in a bag,
and shoved it up my ass
so I could do the cocaine
in the basement
while they were asleep
before they got up
for work at 6:00 a.m.
I did coke
the same way Gollum eats.
The biggest area
of my life it's affected
are my relationships
with my friends,
my friendships.
When I was 20 years old,
I was actually a janitor
at a middle school,
which at the time didn't fit.
Now...
now it looks like it fits.
Like, now...
[laughter]
Now I look like
the guy who's like,
"Hey, if you kids want
to miss dodgeball,
I'll tell you how I got
this hook," you know?
But...
At the time, it didn't fit.
I was very clean...face.
And my friend called me up,
and he said, "Hey, I got tickets
to the Gathering of the Vibes."
It's this jam-band festival
in Upstate New York.
Yeah, I had a really--
I went there in high school.
I had a really fun time there
in high school.
Did a lot of drugs.
I met a chick.
It was fucking great, right?
And I'm 20.
At this point,
I'm getting way more--
like, my fucked-up times
are getting way more dark,
but I'm excited, because I'm,
like, working the shitty job,
my life's in a shitty place.
I'm like, "All right, I have
something to look forward to
on one of these
janitor weekends.
That sounds like
the worst buddy comedy ever.
[imitating announcer]
Get ready for "Janitor Weekend,"
starring Zach Braff
and another Zach.
[normal voice] There's just
a lot of Zachs in that movie.
Anyway, my friend picks me up,
my friend John.
He picks me up.
We stop at the liquor store.
He already should've known
there was gonna be a problem
that weekend,
'cause he got
a 12-pack of beer,
and I bought, like, a handle
of Black Velvet whiskey.
Oh, my God, there's, like--
That's, like, what you drink
in, like, a baby shower
on "Deadwood," you know?
So...
We get in the car.
I'm getting, like,
fucking hammered
the whole trip to this--
And I'm just getting drunker
and drunker.
I'm, like, starting to argue
with him.
Like, it's not making
any sense.
And we get
to the Gathering of the Vibes,
and at this--
Like, Gathering of the Vibes
has changed.
Like, last time I was there,
it was, like, peace, love,
and understanding.
Now there's,
like, one good vibe,
and all the other vibes are,
"I wonder how much ecstasy
I can get
if I steal that guy's iPod,"
you know?
And, like, we're in the car.
We're arguing,
and then all of a sudden,
like, we're on line.
We're, like, in a car line,
waiting to go
into this festival,
and the back door opens,
and I swear to God,
this old man walks in and sit--
He looked like--
Imagine if, like, Burt's Bees
had, like, a cousin,
but instead
of selling bee shit,
he just sold the milk
he squeezed
from possums, you know?
[chuckles]
And he sits down,
and we look at him,
and he just goes,
"Don't mind me.
Passing through."
And he passes out
in the back...
like it was a bonus round
on "Oregon Trail."
But I'm such a drunk.
My friend
doesn't even notice that,
because I'm already fucking--
Like, I'm already yelling
at him.
He's like, "Stop fucking
with the air conditioner."
And I'm like,
"Your mom's an air conditioner."
He's like,
"That doesn't make any sense.
Stop playing
Stevie Nicks' 'Landslide.'"
I'm like, "It's a good song.
Go fuck yourself."
We're fighting back and forth.
We're fighting so much
that in the middle of it,
the old guy just wakes up,
and he goes, "Okay."
And he leaves.
Like, I was so annoying, I made
a hobo turn down shelter.
That's how annoying I was.
He's like,
"I'd rather die in the cold
"than deal with this shit.
I'm going back to Hobo Island."
But we're fighting
more and more.
You know, we're coming down
to the tent area.
He's like, "Fuck you, Dan."
I'm like, "Fuck you."
He's like,
"What's your problem?"
"Man, the Iraq War was wrong."
He's like,
"You're not making any sense."
I jump out of the car
as it's driving.
Now this sounds, like,
very "Lethal Weapon"-y
and impressive,
but the car was only going
10 miles an hour.
So it just looked like
the most low-stakes
hostage situation ever.
So he stops the car.
He runs after me, grabs me,
and he goes,
"What the fuck are you doing?"
And I go, "Living, bro,"
and I punch him in the face
and run away.
Like, there's happy drunk.
There's sad drunk.
I was run-away drunk.
I don't remember much
of the night.
What I do remember
is I remember I had taken
two hits of acid,
and I was nervous,
because I had drank so much,
that I was gonna pass out
and not experience the acid.
So I bought a gram of cocaine
that I immediately did
to my dome.
And I remember I turned to
the guy who sold me the cocaine,
and I'm like,
"Oh, you want to talk now?"
And he goes, "I'm cool,"
and he walks away.
He's probably a doctor now.
And that's all I remember.
I remember I pass out,
and then I woke up the next day,
and I was in my friend's trunk,
and the trunk was open.
And my friend is, like, sitting
in the corner.
Like, he's, like, sitting on one
of those, like, camp chairs,
and he's smoking a cigarette,
and he's looking off
into the distance.
And it's just
that palpable feeling
of "I fucked up," you know?
And I turn to him,
and I'm like...
[meekly]
"Hey, John.
[normal voice]
He goes, "What?"
I go, "I'm sorry."
And he goes,
"Sorry for what?"
"For punching you
in the face."
And then he goes,
"The first time
or the second time?"
Apparently later in the night,
I punched him in the face again.
So it wasn't a good scene.
I walked away.
I found, like,
this little creek near the--
Not a creek, it was, like,
just kind of a ditch.
And I started, like, puking,
'cause I was fucking hungover.
The whole thing was, like,
the most white-trash
Ansel Adams photo ever.
And then this dude comes up
in back of me,
and then I just hear, "Rico?"
And I'm like, "No, no,"
and I start pu--
I'm, like, forcing myself
to puke.
And he's like, "Rico?"
I'm like, "I'm not Rico.
I'm not Rico."
And then he goes,
"No, you're Rico."
I'm like,
"I'm fucking not Ri"--
And then he takes out
his digital camera,
and he shows the pictures,
and I had been partying
with that guy
the night before
and told him my name was Rico.
[chuckles]
And, like, I'm like,
"I'm so sorry.
He goes, "No, don't worry, man.
You were fucking hilarious.
"You told great stories.
"You helped my friend Mike
through a breakup.
You, like, played him this
Bob Dylan song that helped."
And then he goes,
"How's law school going?"
I told him I was going
to law school.
"Yeah, it's good.
It's good."
And then he goes, "Dude, dude,
come here. Come here."
And then he, like, puts
a fucking clump of mushrooms
in my hand.
And I look at it, and I'm like,
"Well, when
in Upstate New York..."
And I eat the mushrooms.
Cut to, like, a half hour later.
At this point, I'm, like,
starting to feel the body buzz,
and he goes, "Hey, dance for us
like you did last night."
And I'm like, "What?"
So I start dancing,
and they think it's hilarious,
but I think it's sexy,
'cause I'm tripping.
Like, it looked like if Jabba
danced for Leia, you know?
It was, like, the opposite
of what it normally is, so...
And then I start dancing
away from them,
but then they follow me,
and we're all dancing
in this line
through the festival.
And in the distance,
I see my friend John,
and he looks at us and goes,
"What the fuck, Dan?"
And then the guy
in back of me goes,
"It's not Dan.
It's Rico."
And then he goes,
"It's fucking Dan!"
He's like, "No, it's Rico!"
And then John's like,
"It's Dan."
And then the guy reaches
into his pocket,
pulls out some more mushrooms,
goes up to my friend John,
puts it in his hand,
and my friend John looks
at the mushrooms.
He goes, "You know...
"you know,
Dan was rude, obnoxious,
"violent, and drunk
last night, but...
"this guy Rico, well...
he seems pretty cool."
And he ate the mushrooms,
and we all partied together.
It was--Two rehabs later,
I'm still dancing.
Guys, thank you so much.
Have a good night.
[cheers and applause]